WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Hi.
I'm Wayne Piekarski for
"The Developer Show".
This is your weekly update
on the coolest developer
news from Google.
We recently launched a brand
new free e-learning platform
to help you understand
the best practices
and Play Console features
to grow your audience,
understand performance metrics,
increase revenue, and more.
Follow the link in the
description below to sign up
and start today.
The Firebase Summit happened
this week in Prague,
and the team announced
the Firebase Management
API, enhanced face
detection with ML Kit,
local emulators for Cloud
Firestore and the Real Time
Database, and a whole lot more.
For all the updates and a
link to the session videos,
head on over to the post.
We recently introduced the Cloud
Key Management Service secrets
engine for the
HashiCorp Vault. Which
means, if you're
a Vault user, you
can now manage Cloud KMS keys,
encrypt and decrypt data,
and sign and verify data
using a familiar Vault API.
For more details and
some example commands,
take a look at the post.
You can now use Google Cloud
DNS as the authoritative name
server to resolve your
domains on the internet
through public DNS zones,
and use private DNS zones
to perform internal
DNS resolutions
for your private GCP networks.
Click through to the post
for a diagram and a link
to the documentation.
There are a whole bunch of
new updates in Chrome 71 Beta,
including relative time
formats, the persistent storage
property for the permission
API, async touchpad pinch zoom
events, and more.
Take a look at the post
linked in the description
below for all the details.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Wayne Piekarski for
"The Developer Show".
Thanks for watching and
we'll see you next week.
I think it was good.
SPEAKER 2: On a scale of no
thumbs up to two thumbs up.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: 3 1/2 thumbs.